so we're uh just about a little bit past
halfway into the film and the character
of balrom who is a
servant to this family to um priyanka
and raj morales characters
they've been involved in a terrible
hit-and-run accident um a couple of
nights ago where
priyanka's character and her birthday
night kind of drunkenly
crashes into a homeless kid in the
street barham's character adarsha's
character has come in as the servant
and thinks he's going to be maybe
rewarded for helping take care of his
masters that night get him out of that
situation
but instead something very different is
about to happen that
becomes the turning point of the film
when i was walking through that door i
remember feeling this this
surge of excitement and this feeling of
pride that i'd done my master's
by you know by sort of um driving
themselves off the scene and sort of
like
saving their life and um i felt like i
would be rewarded honestly when i
when i walked through that door
have you spoken with anyone about what
happened last night
and it's tricky because you know like
you there are retakes and then you've
got to go through that same emotion over
and over again but i tried
like being as transparent and as open to
that emotion as possible so much
happening in those silences where i
somewhere i compromise there's a
plethora of emotions going on
you know inside i think in a choke's
mind at that point of time
there's such a truth to his eyes and
when
his character goes from having the sense
of faith and belief
in you know his employers they're
humanizing him
and when others face changes and the
camera kind of just creeps up and his
eyes look up with a sense of
bewilderment and disappointment
i mean to me this scene is a master
class from the director
and the actor do make the following
statement of my own free will
on the night of november 3rd this year i
drove the car
that hit an unidentified person or
persons or objects
support yeah as he's reading the
confession
letter i wanted the camera to move
towards his face to just be
really that we would feel like we were
experiencing it with him
because it was the most important scene
of the film probably or one of them
and alone responsible
we have already told your family it's so
genius the way it's
executed and it's so genius the way he's
embodied
such a complex amount of emotions it's
beautiful to me it's
like but ram just experiences like a
host of emotions right i mean it's
it's going from excitement to sort of
being in shock to what he's read
being confused um and also
feeling angry at the same time but i
mean none of that can really come across
because he's with his masters and he's
not really allowed to
express how he feels right if he doesn't
know how to write he can press his thumb
he knows how to write
stop treating him like an idiot keep
quiet we shouldn't do this
we shouldn't do this it's not right why
don't you and pinky go to the police
station and tell them what happened
if you understand law then handle this
otherwise they'll shut up
but i think for me most of all the
overriding emotion was
disappointment and ashok when i see him
not standing up for me
and when i see him being quiet and yeah
i mean that
that really hit me and now just go on
well you know something really horrible
has happened and and both me and pinky
madame
franco's character we are feeling awful
about it
and none of us ever wanted this to
happen uh and we wanted to do something
about it we wanted to go and find the
girl
but our families they they didn't allow
us you know because they they thought
that we don't know how the system
works here we don't know the the
complexities of how things function
in the system and that's when they
called
balram a driver and i knew why he was
coming here
and i was feeling pathetic about it but
there's so many there's so many emotions
going on inside inside
inside me at that point of time there's
a there's kind of an uh volcanic
eruption going on
i wanted to raise my voice i tried i
tried in between
try to you know tell them that what
you're doing is wrong it's not right
[Music]
it's that frustration or something
that's that's happened that's beyond my
control
and the situation sort of slipping out
of my hands and i don't know i don't
know what to do about it
i find myself lost in this alien city
that i don't know nothing
that i know nothing off i find myself
surrounded by these people
who i thought were like my family but
they've just like turned around and
like backstabbed me so it's all of that
coming together
i like the part after it's it's when he
comes outside
we've been closed for so long i wanted
to be very high and wide
to see him so isolated and lonely i
love that choice by the way of of going
from
you know a complete tight close-up of
understanding exactly what he's feeling
to completely being abandoned by
all of these people who five seconds ago
were being his best friend and now he's
alone you know in this gaudy environment
there was some tall grass growing some
weeds and i
asked you what did it remind you of and
you said it reminded you of the village
and i said me too
and i think there may be something there
for you to do something to find
you looked up at all those buildings so
i quickly went and got a pov shot of
that dizzying
feeling and then you went and you curled
up in that ball
i found that always so powerful when i
see the film your
your discovery of that moment
this is a scene in the second half of
the film shortly after
balram the servant has been forced to
sign a confession for a hit-and-run
accident which killed a young homeless
kid although he was not the driver
in fact priyanka's character was
drunkenly driving that light with her
husband played by rajkumar
they have some news they wanted to give
to adarsha's character ballroom the
servant
paolo the cinematographer and i were
talking that we've been in this living
room a lot we wanted to do something
different
and so i encouraged him to close the
curtains and backlight the stork
which then gave us this added uh bonus
of a shadow and a light coming across
barham's face when he entered um it just
gave the scene a different mood and
feeling
i mean this is an extremely complex
scene for my character
she in her head thinks she's a
conscientious person in her head she
thinks that i'm a woke person
she comes back and relates with balram
and says you know you shouldn't be
working with us
and you should be thinking about your
future but
she's the one driving the car and when
the family get him to sign
the confession she goes with it and
she's
guilt-ridden they have a contact at the
police
no one reported seeing what what i did
so
they don't need you anymore it was
really crucial for pinky to
sit with him it was some sort of
validation of saying all right now i'm
washing myself off of the sins of even
going with this plan
by sitting next to you and by being on
your level
i think i'd already imagined myself
getting punished for for something that
i didn't even do
like the reaction that i had was is this
a is this again like one of your cruel
jokes or is this actually happening
yeah first i just want to say that i
think priyanka is absolutely brilliant
in the scene why would you kick him kam
churro salah
why would you hit him like that hey
pinkie pinky how can you just do that
it's like
don't you tell me to calm down it's like
you don't even care
after the scene or before we shot it you
were talking to me about
part of your anger and hitting the stork
was somehow your anger with yourself
because i you were
some part of you were was hiding deep
down somewhere that you knew you were
responsible for all this and it was
coming out in this way so i
i remember there were so many things
going on in your head that day how you
were going to express them all at once
it was misplaced rage you know the
reason why she acted out like that
within an indian family there is no
world in which you physically
hit your father-in-law like that's that
doesn't happen
that would not happen and and then also
to raise your voice and
in an all-male environment um as the
only female in the scene
i felt like there was a lot of things
that required stepping up
what you're doing just you get away from
me it's all you know
at this point of time is somebody who is
so helpless and he just
is somebody who just stuck between his
family and his wife
though he knows exactly what his wife is
saying is right that's the point where
you know the family starts making him
like one of them that you have to
control your wife you have to be this
that's the breaking point of the of the
marriage the way we did the scene was
pretty organic i think that means the
process is just to
be in the moment and just to react to
the situation that's exactly i think we
have made
the most of the film and this scene is
is one of them it was really rich and i
had such a
great time actually doing this thing
there was so much going on
and it was priyanka's instincts and her
great performance that
anchored me and allowed me to film the
scene and that's why i love working with
her she just
brings the best to every scene